pourquoi l'essence est-elle encore aussi
chère en France alors que les prix
baissent un peu partout en Europe
l'écart atteints parfois 30 centimes et
pourtant le prix d'achat du pétrole
baisse et bien ce matin une association
de consommateurs accuse les
distributeurs de fer des marges abusives
début 2022 pour le gasoil leur marge se
situait autour de 18 centimes de rôle au
litre en avril elle atteint les 29
centimes 25% du gasoil qui était en
France était russe jusqu'en mois de
janvier et donc on a changé de
fournisseur on a changé de circuit de
commercialisation c'est un vrai choix
qui sont plus cher qui coûte plus cher
Agnès panier rue naché ministre de la
transition énergétique appelle elle
aussi les distributeurs abaissés leurs
prix l'un de lui répond qu'elle se
trompe de cible par exemple les
Allemands nous ont dit mais chez nous en
une semaine deux semaines la réforme
elle aurait été enterrée tout simplement
parce que chez nous il y a une
démocratie sociale que vous n'avez pas
en France il y a aussi une démocratie
politique que vous n'avez pas en France
moi je trouve quand même assez gonflé
que une ministre s'adresse au
distributeur et pas aux fournisseur
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
souhaitons abroger ces deux années
supplémentaires et nous souhaitons en
appeler à une grande conférence sociale
ce que nous faisons confiance au
dialogue social on sait qu'il y a une
discipline de faire dans le parti avec
des menaces et des pressions fortes sur
les élus c'est d'ailleurs un vrai
problème mais on sait aussi qu'il y a un
certain nombre de députés qui entendent
ce qui se passe dans la circonscription
c'est pour lui j'ajoute une opportunité
de sortir par le haut de cette crise ou
bien que partout il sort il a contrôlé
les casseroles l'opinion publique les
milices peuvent pas sortir on a quatre
ans pour diriger le pays encore on peut
pas fonctionner comme ça les lois il
sera présentée en conseil des ministres
au mois de juillet à l'issue d'une
concertation qui a été confiée au
ministre de l'Intérieur général de
Darmanin ils avaient eu des petits
appels du gouvernement avec des
propositions pour leur circonscriptions
si jamais il votait les choses comme
comme il fallait donc il y a aussi des
manœuvres qui sont un vrai problème pour
notre démocratie
c'est mieux qu'une série Netflix cette
réforme de l'immigration avec du
suspense avec des rebondissements et du
tirage entre les acteurs voilà ce que
nous offre cette réforme de
l'immigration et une précision sur la
méthode el timing mais aucun revient et
Emmanuel Macron a tranché ou plutôt il a
décidé de faire du en même temps il
demande à sa première ministre de faire
des consultations pendant un mois pour
arrêter une stratégie afin que la
majorité présidentielle se met d'accord
on voit bien que la classe politique le
gouvernement ils sont pas sur la même
longueur d'onde il y a des gens qui sont
pour l'inflation sans doute parce qu'ils
l'ont premier aux industriels certains
distributeurs ont déjà enclenché les
renégociations si jamais ça n'est pas le
cas dans les semaines qui viennent et
qu'on remarque des grands industriels
qui gèrent des marques que vous avez
citées ne font pas d'efforts qu'est-ce
qu'on fera je pense qu'on reviendra
jamais au prix d'avant on reviendra
jamais au prix d'avant faut pas vendre
du rêve je vais le dire autrement on
citera il est clair que aujourd'hui
quand on voit la société médiatique dans
laquelle on est on dira aux Français
sont-elles et telle marque désolé mais
ils veulent pas négocier
une pure terreur écrite alors le
journaliste de 32 ans Harman soldin
accomplissé son métier sa passion sa
vocation il est tombé parce qu'il
voulait faire connaître des faits il est
tombé parce qu'il croyait que le devoir
d'informer ne doit reculer devant rien
Emmanuel Macron a réagi sur Twitter par
ces mots avec courage dès les premières
heures du conflit il était au front pour
établir les faits pour nous informer
l'ancien président Donald Trump a été
reconnu coupable d'agressions sexuelles
sur une ancienne journaliste les faits
se sont déroulés dans la cabine
d'essayage d'un magasin il y a plus de
25 ans il devra lui verser 5 millions de
dollars d'indemnités ce verdict est une
honte à réagi de son côté Donald Trump